on pourrait penser que c'est un poème
secondaire celui des déjections canines
ont pas du tout c'est un problème des
plus difficiles à régler pour toute une
série de raisons et qui fait que
psychologiquement c'est devenir des
problèmes majeurs de la propreté à paris
si les chats et les oiseaux par exemple
pose des problèmes d'hygiène c'est
essentiellement à l'intérieur des
habitations
là c'est au propriétaire d'agir à sa
guise ce n'est pas le cas pour le chien
qui est à l'origine de pollutions à
l'extérieur incontestable pour enrayer
cette pollution les moyens traditionnels
pour ne pas dire archaïque sont peu
efficaces devant les 30 tonnes
d'excréments répandues chaque jour dans
les rues de paris
alors on n'hésite pas à employer les
grands moyens
chaque jour 75 canine est comme celle ci
ratisse 2500 km de trottoirs parisiens
le résultat est souvent efficace mais
les promenades hygiénique des chiens ne
sont pas toujours en concordance avec le
passage de ces engins
c'est une partie importante du coude du
nettoiement peu près 450 millions de
dépenses dans le nettoiement et bien un
tiers qui est dû au nettoyage des
trottoirs et les trottoirs maintenant
sont essentiellement salut par les
chiens ça se fait deux fois par jour en
général s'il ya une une périodicité qui
fait que c'est très difficile de les
enlever
est ce que vous seriez éventuellement
imposer des taxes sur les animaux bien
faire comme à new york par exemple
imposer des amendes à ceux qui nettoient
pas qu'ils font pas attention
je crois que la taxe sur les chiens ne
me paraît pas très raisonnable je crois
que il ya peu de civisme je crois qu'il
faut il faut apprendre
mon français à pirey éduquer leur chien
il faut peut-être éduquer les mettre à
vendre avant des tuques et les chiens et
les éduqueront eux mêmes faire attention
évidemment à ce qui les tiennent en
laisse dans la rue à ce que ce qui leur
apprennent à faire leurs besoins nous ça
ne gêne pas les autres au dessus d'un
jeu tu apprennes de civisme il faut le
résoudre
alors quelle est la solution sur le
terrain apparemment les édicules
séculaire ou plus modernes ne sont pas
faits pour les chiens
en tout cas la canadienne avec
évacuation direct à l'égout semble être
une des solutions
c'est un problème d'éducation conjugué
avec une certaine discipline de la part
des propriétaires et un effort de
dressage on devrait pouvoir arriver à
éliminer la plupart des crottes de
chiens qui sont sur les trottoirs une
situation géographique tous les 500
mètres tous les 800 mètres permettrait
aux gens tout en faisant une promenade
correct et en assurant une promenade
hygiéniques pour le chien de pouvoir
collecter
- la moitié sinon les trois quarts des
excréments
alameda une médaille elle a une médaille
de la ville de paris vous voyez elle n'a
jamais fait un petit pipi ni impôt sur
le trottoir elle est ma victoire
alors dans le caniveau ou directement à
l'égout en tout cas pas sur le trottoir
non d'un chien
[Musique]